I think they're playing with fire the  Commons are going to win this issue one  way or another but the most likely  losers are the House of Lords themselves  if anyone is picked off they should call  call a byelection immediately and we all  campaign for them they can't expel huge  tranches of labour MP you would not find  many politicians who are as scathing  about Brussels as I am at the very same  time my message to my friends here in  Britain is stay with him the Scottish  Labour Party was the party of devolution  but the one mistake we made was not to  devolved the party itself  the Coalition is going to be remembered  with some affection the longer this  government goes on